bienvenue à part une autochtone si c'est
melissa maulin depuis cette semaine j'ai
envie de vous parler d'un sujet qui est
un peu compliqué mais qui évoque quelque
chose de très important pour moi ça
devrait aller cette future génération
mélanger avec le leadership la raison
pour laquelle je me sens inspirée par ce
sujet cette semaine c'est tous les
points de presse quotidiens convoi soit
du premier ministre de monsieur legault
et de tout le toute l'information qui
vient qui émane du leadership justement
ça c'était une des sources d'inspiration
pas ce qui m'a vraiment fait déclencher
sur ce sujet là c'est l'émission
quotidienne de mon chef jean-charles
piétacho à mes gars qui fait une
émission de radio quotidienne depuis
quelques années et dans son émission
habituellement il va il va faire passer
la bonne musique qui va nous parler des
projets qui sont maintenant communauté
mais cette semaine puis dans les
dernières semaines il semblait surtout
servi pour pour nous expliquer les
raisons
pourquoi on prend des décisions pour la
communauté que ce soit les chefs les
conseillers et ce qui est très important
c'est de devoir expliquer certaines
décisions très difficiles mains des
politiques qui viennent est implanté
c'est la fermeture complète des
frontières de la communauté
alors on peut pas ni rentrer les sortir
dans la communauté à moins d'être un
service essentiel ou d'avoir besoin
d'aller faire un rendez-vous médical ça
casse certaines des libertés
individuelles ça nous empêche d'aller
acheter des affaires dans les grandes
surfaces
on a un magasin et communautaire on a
des des ressources mais ça diminue un
peu c'est des petits plaisirs du
quotidien
cependant la décision n'est pas facile
parce que c'est une décision qui vient
toucher des gens d'une communauté avec
laquelle tu habites donc des critiques
si on les suit quotidiennement des
questionnements du veau aussi du monde
qui vont pas écouter les décisions qui
ont été prises
même si c'est fait au nom de la
communauté
mais le plus en plus la communauté
justement mon bac non ses prises de
décision parce que justement elles sont
faites en réflexion du bien-être de la
communauté en entier
et ça ça m'a fait vraiment beaucoup
réfléchir aux cette future général ceux
qui connaissent pas le concept de cette
future génération c'est que toute
décision ou choix qui est fait doit être
en reste et puis en réflexion 17 futures
générations c'est-à-dire 125 à 140 ans
on a vu en avant de toi c'est pas
évident de penser à toutes les
conséquences de tes choix des décisions
mais toujours de réfléchir dans cette
direction là ça permet de faire des
choix sont éclairés bien sûr le concept
est galvaudé je pense particulièrement à
des compagnies gazifières de pipelines
qui vont décider de s'appeler cette
future génération utilise le concept
produire ce projet économique sera
excellent pour les cette future
génération bla bla bla c'est pas dans
cet angle là qu'il faut la voir c'est
vraiment dans l'angle d'une décision
pour le bien de tous habituellement on
va utiliser ce concept là en
environnement mais l'on peut l'appliquer
justement à la santé et au bien-être de
la communauté
mon chef dans son dans son émission
expliquait justement que il ya des
réflexions qui sont faites pas ce qu'on
pense aux conséquences et d'y demander à
vos aînés qu'est ce qui s'est passé
pendant la grippe espagnole et lui
réfléchissait beaucoup aussi à
l'histoire d'un des membres de ma
famille que d'autres membres de la
communauté qui ont été touchés par une
autre maladie infectieuse c'est à dire
la tuberculose la tuberculose à faire
encore et encore aujourd'hui des ravages
dans les communautés autochtones un peu
partout quelles sont ses premières
nations ou chez les ennemis d'un an
cela dit que devrait avoir disparu mais
on est malheureusement encore pris avec
on peut avoir des soins qui vont durer
quelques semaines quelques mois mais
certaines personnes
à l'époque je pense pas juste des
premières nations les québécois aussi
devait aller dans des sanatoriums pour
des années même longueur d'une vie était
pris dans à prendre soin dans les
sanatoriums donc vous pouvez imaginer ça
c'est des conséquences à long terme pour
une maladie infectieuse on voit
certaines des conséquences de tomber
malade du que vides on voit certaines
des conséquences physiques mais on
réfléchit pas non plus les conséquences
psychologiques culturel social que
maladie peut amener dans une communauté
la perte d'un aîné c'est la perte d'une
encyclopédie de la culture de la
communauté qui est vivante
la perte d'une mère de famille par
exemple ou d'un père de famille c'est la
perte du pilier d'une famille donc on
voit des conséquences pour les 4-7
futures générations
mais où ne les calcule pas quand
j'entends justement les commentaires les
critiques dans les live stream des
premiers ministres on voit souvent
repartir l'économie
sauver des gens repartir l'économie
c'est comme un débat et malheureusement
ce qui fêterait pas c'est justement dans
une culture de leadership ou tu te fait
élire à toutes les quatre ou à quelques
années près la popularité est importante
donc les choix que tu veux faire tourner
vers les structures génération sont
toujours influencées par ton devoir de
te faire et les pouvoirs de réélection
et c'est très difficile de ne pas penser
toujours est ce qu'ils vont faire le bon
choix pour la communauté où est ce
qu'ils vont faire le bon choix pour eux
et après la communauté on le voit aux
états unis présentent pas les
conséquences de ce genre de choix là où
la communauté pas ses attraits
l'économie et maintenant on voit les
morts on voit les malades les
conséquences monétaires aussi parce que
nous on a des soins de santé une
quartier peut donc présentement j'avoue
que je vois cette direction qui est pris
par le gouvernement qu'un bas vers le
communautaire mais on voit aussi comment
les changements les pressions
comment les la direction des décision
est prise aussi en fonction de toutes
les petites voix en arrière ça soit les
voix de l'économie les voix des
entrepreneurs
parce qu'ils veulent sauver l'économie
mais ça peut être au détriment justement
des individus et souvent les individus
les moins les moins capables de se
défendre physiquement contre une maladie
aussi c'était aussi grave si je peux
finir sur quelque chose qui est une
inspiration pour moi c'est
la loi de la confédération iroquoise
yens dedans il ya justement en lien avec
les futures générations
une référence justement au leadership où
ils disent que sur ta tête jeu mais
maintenant les bois du chevreuil
tu es le roi de la forêt d'enfants qui
devient leader un chef mais cependant
maintenant tu dois tu as remis d'une
peau épaisse comme les cet anneau d'un
arbre c'est à dire cette génération
d'année d'arbres pour te protéger contre
la critique de protéger contre le désir
de venger contre la violence et ça fera
de toi un meilleur chef donc dans cette
perspective de cette future génération
de cette vision que le leadership doit
avoir il faut aussi que ces deux types
doivent faire ses choix et des fois ne
pas prendre des critiques
personnellement le port se laisser
influencer est restée solide sur des
décisions sans bien sûr se fermer à
l'ecoute de sa communauté
et ça je pense que c'est un des messages
que je vois beaucoup avec mon chef il
reste toujours à l'écouté mais il doit
prendre des décisions qui sont très
difficiles et ça c'est peut-être plus
facile à gérer quand dans une communauté
plus étaient fermés ou tête à communauté
te parle
et c'était un peu plus inquiétant qu'on
parle d'un leadership de très très très
très très grande envergure comme tout
être premier ministre du canada
là où certaines des voix qui ont accès à
toi ce ne sont pas les voix de la
communauté donc c'est certain que vous
pouvez voir comment cette inquiétude là
peut nourrir justement d'audition nos
choix et commander fois justement nos
préférences personnelles nos libertés
personnelles vont peut-être des fois
prendre le dessus sur des décisions qui
vont protéger la communauté
donc c'est sûr en s'inspirant du passé
en s'inspirant des éditions qui ont été
faites par les communautés autrefois on
peut voir d'édition d'avenir pour la
communauté pour le processus est donc
les divisions ne devient pas le centre
de la communauté mais la communauté
devient au centre de l'individu qui
devient lui le protecteur par ses choix
et ses décisions
on tournait vers de cette future
génération alors j'espère vous avoir
inspiré de rechercher un peu plus
justement sur la loi de la confédération
extraordinairement intéressante à lire
n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer des
questions n'hésitez pas justement nous
donner des pistes
c'est un trouble pour que l'on puisse y
répondre
c'est une belle semaine